venom first sank his teeth into fans
brains decades ago and the pages of the
amazing spider-man comics giving the
antihero a long time to build up a cast
of kookie side characters not
surprisingly a handful of those familiar
names made their way into 20 18s venom
the symbiotes first solo big-screen
outing here are some of the characters
in venom who have way more meaning than
you realized
major spoilers ahead and weighing in
venom Michelle Williams plays and
weighing Eddie Brock's fiance who dumps
him after he snuck information about the
life foundation out of her personal
files and then accosted the foundation
CEO Carlton Drake in an interview the
move gets both of them fired and waying
breaks off their engagement she later
gets catapulted back into his life when
venom takes over her body so that she
can carry him back to Eddie for a few
minutes audiences were treated to a
giant head eating female venom that
bizarre version of venom comes straight
out of the comic book miniseries sinner
takes all in that arc venom bonds with
Anne to save her life after Anne gets
shot later in the series they pull the
same trick to get out of a hostage
situation
saving the day by way of perfectly
planned body swapping Carlton Drake 2018
s venom saw Riz Ahmed channeling the
prototypical bad guy in this character
Carlton Drake he's an amoral scumbag who
eventually gets a symbiote of his very
own he invented punch each other a lot
and then one of them explodes in the
comics however there's a bit more to
this guy's story like many of Venom's
adversaries Carlton Drake was originally
a spider-man villain he and his
nefarious Life Foundation first showed
up in the amazing spider-man number 298
and it only took him a few issues to
throw an army of mutated monsters at
Spidey
his big clash with venom came in venom
lethal protector which also served as
one of the storylines Sony's venom film
was based on in that series
Drake concocts a plan to steal five
pieces of venom and nurture them into
his own symbiote super soldiers he
succeeds creating scream phage Lasher
agony and riot eventually spider-man and
venom put a stop to this particular plan
sending Drake back into hiding to
concoct bigger more devious schemes
which culminate in drake turning himself
into a giant spider in the Iraq Miss
Project story arc Roland Treece
he didn't have a lot going on in the
movie but Scott Hayes delivered a pretty
good henchman as rolling trees sure you
got his head eaten in the end but it's
the journey that counts unfortunately in
this case that journey should have been
a whole lot bigger in his comics
incarnation Treece isn't a low-level
thug who goes out to crummy apartments
to retrieve his boss's lost aliens he's
an ultra rich businessman who sits on
the board of directors for the life
foundation granted he's still less of a
threat to venom than Drake but it's
Teresa's master plan to demolished part
of the city that sent Spidey and venom
running back to San Francisco for the
final showdown in lethal protector
that's all fine the venom movie didn't
need multiple masterminds for its crazy
schemes and there were already enough
bad guys to go around at least the movie
didn't try to shoehorn in venom source
Rex wait who are we kidding
venom source Rex would have been the
best addition to this movie screen in
the first act of the movie we're
introduced to some Tanks of goo in the
life foundation labs those are the
symbiotes that Drake is trying to merge
with human hosts a project that goes
disastrously wrong if you pay close
attention you may have noticed that one
of the symbiotes was distinctly yellow
which matches another distinctly yellow
symbiote in the comics scream in venom
lethal protector Donna Diego was the
human host for scream one of the five
symbiotes created by Drake she
eventually obtained a measure of
self-awareness and gained enough control
over her symbiote to start hunting the
other ones fans on the internet
speculated that the EMT who bonds with
the symbiote was in fact Donna Diego
although we now know that that lady was
just a brief host for the riot symbiote
her inclusion and the fact that she got
more screen time than the other hosts
could be another nod to Donna Diego
maybe Cletus Kasady before the reviews
were even in venom was already setting
up a sequel and it's spider las' spider
verse in the mid credit scene we see
woody harrelson make an appearance as a
red haired psychopath in a prison cell
who goes by the name Cletus Kasady
comics fans should instantly recognize
the name as the inmate who played host
of Venom's son carnage Cassady is gone
he maybe Venom's son but carnage is
stronger and a whole lot crazier than
dear old dad if a venom sequel gets off
the ground a woody harrelson played
carnage could be just the ticket to take
things to the next level
[Music]